[Music]
the earth may not be our home forever
eventually we may have to leave what if
instead of finding a potentially
habitable exoplanet light-years away we
stayed in our solar system and built a
habitat so enormous
we could never over populate it this is
what if and here's what would happen if
we built a ringed world in space
imagine you lived on a ring with a
radius of 150 million kilometers
encircling the Sun a gigantic artificial
world with its own gravity ecosystem and
atmosphere big enough for trillions of
humans to call home
you'd live on an enormous landmass on
the inner side of the Ring the outer
shell would protect you and all those
trillions of people from the hazards of
outer space
how does that sound yeah great problem
is assembling such a thing suspended out
in the solar system wouldn't be easy
you couldn't just pull the earth apart
and have an army of robots reassemble it
into a ring world among the many
problems you'd run into your first would
be finding the material the
International Space Station roaming the
Earth's lower orbit right now weighs
about four hundred and twenty tons
something like a ringed world would tip
the scales at no less than a million
tons where would we find all this
material I know some places the Kuiper
belt beyond the orbit of Neptune would
do just fine this ring of icy body
stretches out for almost 3 billion
kilometres some astronomers think the
Kuiper belt would have enough material
for this project but it's hard to tell
exactly how much we'd need to construct
a thing like this we might have to
sacrifice all the planets moons and
asteroids in the solar system our ring
world and the Sun would be the only
things left if we could manage to gather
and transport all the material available
then construction would begin it would
take a lot of physical labor an army of
robots and maybe hundreds of generations
to realize that our
structure was not stable enough because
the mega structure would turn out so
enormous it would break any known
molecular bonds we'd have to find a way
to make use of one of the fundamental
forces of nature the strong nuclear
force of all forces
it's the grip iasts it bonds material on
the scale of atomic nucleus so that
nothing can break it apart or maybe we'd
come up with a new super-strong material
all together but until we figure that
out every interstellar body passing
through our solar system would be a
threat to our mega structure the next
thing we'd have to worry about is
gravity and that part is pretty easy we
just have to spin the Ringworld at
nearly 2 million kilometers per hour
I know that's really fast we'd have to
build up that speed over time
luckily maintaining it in the
frictionless environment of space
wouldn't be too hard such rotation would
generate centrifugal force and that in
turn would create an artificial gravity
equal to the one we have here on earth
with gravity solved we bring in the
atmosphere and start populating the Ring
world for the inhabitants of the mega
structure it would always be daytime
unless we could create a day and night
cycle with extra panels inside the ring
but for all the epicness of the world we
just created
it wouldn't be stable a single asteroid
strike could cause the structure to
drift closer to the Sun a hole punch
through the ring could let all our
atmosphere out and a massive solar storm
don't even get me started on that one
one failure inside the ring could doom
the entire structure together with its
inhabitants it's just too risky to build
it around the Sun we might have better
luck with a huge ring space station in
the Earth's orbit but that's a story for
another what-if
you